[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Hey, everyone.
Welcome to "Eyes on
Enterprise," where
I'm bringing on Googlers to
talk about the technology
landscapes that are
helping enterprises scale,
adapt, and modernize.
My name is Stephanie
Wong, and today I
have Sona Oakley, Solution
Architect here at Google Cloud.
Very important topic that
we're covering today--
we're talking about
migration to the Cloud
and diving into
strategies and the tools
to help you get there.
There's a lot that we're
going to cover today,
so I want to thank you so
much for being on the show.
SONA OAKLEY: Absolutely.
Thank you so much for having me.
I'm really excited
to come on the show
and talk about migrations.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Great, so huge topic.
First off, migration
is something
that people often consider
for a long period of time
because they have rightful
concerns over moving
their workloads to the Cloud.
And then, on top of
that, small companies
versus large companies have
different needs and migration
paths.
So how do you start to
dissect that process?
SONA OAKLEY: Yes, absolutely.
I would say that the first thing
that you want to start with,
because migrations is
such a heavy topic,
is, you want to
start with the why.
Ask yourself the question,
why are we going down
this path, what is going to
be the business goal that I'm
accomplishing, or even the
technical goal that I'm
accomplishing.
And once you kind of frame
that and keep that in mind,
it really makes it
clear how we can
get from where your
company is today to where
it is that you want to be.
And whether that's being able to
develop faster, whether that's
being able to take advantage
of all of the efficiencies
and scale that moving
to the Cloud can bring,
it'll really vary
based on your business
and how big your business is,
what your business goals are.
STEPHANIE WONG:
So there are a lot
of ways to move to the
Cloud and along with it
many considerations when
you're picking a strategy.
You know, some companies want
to decommission some workloads.
They want to consolidate.
Others want to move
their VM to the Cloud.
And others want to
modernize by transforming
into the containers.
So how do you start in that
decision-making process?
SONA OAKLEY:
Essentially, the way
that you would want
to think about it
is that once we have that
North Star that we want
to accomplish, we want
to go back to square one
and really start to
build a catalog of all
of the applications that
you have, the workloads
that you're thinking
about moving,
what your networking and
security requirements are.
And once we've categorized
and built out that list,
we can start to think about
what our migration strategy is
moving forward.
Now, when I say that, a lot
of people think in their minds
that they need a very
complicated system
diagram, where there's all
these connections taking place--
you know, where we have the
exact schematics of the way
that our applications work.
For larger enterprises
and businesses
that have grown organically,
sometimes that's not feasible.
So I would say that
coming to the table
with anything, even if
it's just a napkin, which
has happened to me--
a customer showed
up with a napkin
of just all their applications
and workloads written down
that they wrote
down on the flight
to come up to Mountain View.
So I would say that even
something that simple
gives us a good starting
point and gives us
an idea of at least what
is top-of-mind for you.
And then we can go
through and dig through
with the other various
groups and lines of business
that you have to figure out what
are other applications, what
are other resources
that are being used.
STEPHANIE WONG: So going
back to the first part
of the workflow-- collecting
inventory-- it can include
a lot of things like
dependencies on your app stack,
including your database
and message brokers.
And then you have your
infrastructure underlying it,
firewall rules,
security policies.
Am I missing anything there?
SONA OAKLEY: I mean, that
really covers the meat of it.
And then things like
source code repositories--
oftentimes, the
gotchas happen when
a business grows organically.
And we see people coming
out of the woodwork
as this migration
process is happening.
Hey, actually I'm keeping my
source code over here and not
in the official repository.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
SONA OAKLEY: Or if I've
got this machine that I'm
using 2% of CPU on for, you
know, my own workloads-- things
like that.
STEPHANIE WONG: Comprehensive
evaluation ahead of time
is going to save
you in the long run.
SONA OAKLEY: Yes.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
I know that there
are a lot of cases where
moving to the Cloud
may not be practical,
or it's just not
technically feasible
in the near-term.
So you know, like,
for example, you
have licenses that you
can't move to the Cloud
or your tech stack may not be
virtualizable in some cases
or you have third-party
frameworks and languages being
used.
So what do you do
in those cases?
SONA OAKLEY: Yeah, I would
say that in those cases,
it's OK to say no.
And sometimes, no
is the right answer.
For example, you know,
mainframes are not going away.
We've predicted that they
will be for the past 40 years.
And they're here to stay.
So if you have legacy
applications that
are running in those
kinds of environments,
it's totally fine to
leave them where they are
and then to focus on
what we can accomplish
because the last
thing we want to do
is kind of get into a situation
where we're trying to force
a square peg into round hole.
And we can also do
something that's
a close approximation
to moving to Cloud.
So for example, I was
working with a company
that was getting close to
a data center shut down.
And so instead of
having them move over
completely to the
Cloud, what we did was,
we moved them to a
co-location facility.
And what that allowed
them to do was,
it allowed them to still
reap some of the benefits
because they're still located
close to a Cloud entry point
and are able to get
that high throughput,
low latency that they were
looking for without doing
the official Cloud migration.
STEPHANIE WONG: So just
jumping off what you just said,
there are a lot of
ways to approach this.
And you have to meet
customers where they are.
And you know, some may want
to do an all-in-one Lift
and Shift, while others prefer
to do a hybrid approach--
private and public Cloud.
So how do you advise
your customers on that?
SONA OAKLEY: Absolutely.
I would say that it,
again, comes back
to what the customer wants.
You know, if most
of your business
is on legacy applications
and hardware,
we'll have to consider a
very different migration path
than if you're already
Cloud-native and looking
to scale.
So for example,
we actually worked
with a customer who had
very aggressive timelines
to shut down their data center.
Again, this is a
very familiar story.
And what we did was, we
advised them to kind of Lift
and Shift their current
applications as-is
and then modernize
later because they
were facing a
really imminent time
crunch that we wanted to make
sure that we could adhere to.
And then we can always
modernize those applications
and advise on a
containerization strategy
at a later point in time.
Don't feel like you have to do
everything at the same time.
STEPHANIE WONG: On the
topic of containerization,
people often ask, OK, how do
I know if my application is
a good candidate for
containerizing and pushing up
to the Cloud.
Things like Dev-Test
applications,
multi-tier stacks,
LAMP applications,
or perhaps you have a Java app
running on Premise web apps--
how do you know?
SONA OAKLEY: Google
can absolutely
help you in that
effort-- you know,
especially once we've done that
categorization of applications.
But generally, the
ones that you mentioned
are good for containerization.
I would also include in there
are things like training labs--
you know, thinking, also,
about your application.
If it's resilient to
restarts, then that
is a good one, as well,
to be moving over.
And you know, again,
it just goes back
to making sure that
you're not trying to force
a containerization strategy.
I was working with a
large-scale manufacturing
company who really wanted
to go all-in on containers.
But due to their kind of
technical requirements,
it wasn't the
right fit for them.
So instead, we moved them
onto system containers,
which still gives them a
little bit of that flexibility
but isn't that full-container
portfolio that we
were originally thinking about.
STEPHANIE WONG:
So this still begs
the question, what do you do
with monolithic applications
because, I mean, a
lot of enterprises
are still running off that.
How do you migrate to a
microservice environment?
SONA OAKLEY: The
way that I think
about that is, if you're
thinking about scaling
a building or
scaling a mountain,
you don't try to jump all the
way up to the top at one time.
You know, you take it
step-by-step and really
go incrementally.
As your team learns more about
Google Cloud and Kubernetes
and containerization, we can
break down that application
and move toward more of
a microservices strategy.
One of the things
that Google has
done that's a little bit
of a nice middle ground
there is using
application containers.
So instead of thinking
about containerization
in the normal context,
an application container
allows you to put
the application--
entire application--
into a container.
And so, that way, you can still
take advantage of the higher
fault tolerance and portability
that containerization provides
without necessarily
moving or breaking down
that monolithic
application all at once.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right, because
I think that what's intimidating
is a full rearchitecture
of these applications.
SONA OAKLEY: Yes, absolutely.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, I love
this idea of middle ground
and moving in parts because it
lowers the risk and the barrier
to entry to Cloud migration.
And you can still take
advantage of, like,
the software-defined networking,
live migration, fast reboots.
But I do want to talk about
specifics a little bit--
about the tools that exist
to help you migrate, like,
for example, moving Compute
workloads to the Cloud.
Do we have anything there?
SONA OAKLEY: Absolutely.
So we have Migrate
for Compute Engine.
And essentially, what
that allows you to do,
whether you're moving one
workload or thousands,
it provides you a unified way to
move all of these componentries
over to Google Compute
Engine, which is GCE.
It also provides cloud
testing and validation.
We have a plug-in that
makes it really simple
to kind of find those
workloads and move them over.
And then lastly, which I think
is the most critical part--
and you touched on
this at the beginning--
is that we have a
stateful rollback.
So if, at any point,
you feel like you
need to hit the ejector
button and really just get out
of the migration, we
have that capability,
where you can roll back to
your on-premise environment.
We can pause, take a timeout,
and see what's happening.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yes, and
that's very important
because, once again,
you want to make
sure you have compatibility
towards the Cloud first
and you're not creating
disruption for your user base.
So being able to roll
back is a key, I think.
SONA OAKLEY: Yes, absolutely.
One of the customer examples
that I always like to use
is that we had a Fortune 500
company who was using SAP,
actually.
Implement a-- they
were originally
considering a
Multicloud strategy,
and then they moved over to GCP.
And what we helped
them do was, we
helped them run SAP on
Google Cloud Platform, which
was really important because
they were part of the pharma
business.
And that was important for
their pharma and healthcare
verticals.
We, all-in-all, I
believe covered something
like 7,000 systems across
30 different applications
with 12 terabytes of
data moving on to GCP.
And all of that was done with
Migrate for Compute Engine.
STEPHANIE WONG: Wow, great.
Another great example of
a very common use case
is VMware migration
to the cloud.
Do we have a tool that
exists for that, as well?
SONA OAKLEY: If you've
decided that retaining
use of a VMware-based
control plane
is what's appropriate
for your business,
we can actually support that.
And we have support for
VMware vSphere workloads
that we can move over onto
Google Cloud Platform.
STEPHANIE WONG: Awesome.
So what about the
applications that do
need to stay
on-premise, yet they
want to take advantage of the
Cloud native capabilities?
What do we recommend
in those cases?
SONA OAKLEY: Earlier
in 2019, Google Cloud
came out with a new
product called Anthos.
And essentially, that platform
does exactly what you asked.
We have seen that customers
are running their applications
on-premise in Google Cloud as
well as other cloud providers.
And the management of
that becomes very ornery.
Now you're looking at
separate config managements,
separate monitoring platforms,
separate logging platforms.
And Anthos seeks to
unify all of that.
We pull all of the underlying
hardware together and allow you
to manage your on-premise
and your hybrid cloud--
Multicloud environments
in one place.
If we do have a
little bit deeper,
the way that we do it on-premise
is that we have a tool
called GKE On-Premise,
which allows
you to implement
a containerization
strategy in your
on-premise environments.
STEPHANIE WONG: Do
you have an example
of a customer that is leveraging
Anthos and using on-premise
and Cloud together?
SONA OAKLEY: Yes.
Actually, we have a very
big banking customer
who's using Cisco HyperFlex
as well as Anthos today
to really do exactly that.
They've found that it's
been able to simplify
their monitoring, logging,
and config management.
And they're still
able to get access
to all the benefits of Cloud.
And it's as if they were
deployed cloud-native,
but their underlying
hardware is still on-premise.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
that just reminded
me-- another exciting
announcement was Migrate
for Anthos, which
I know actually
lets customers move their
VM-based workloads to the cloud
and convert them
into containers,
which is amazing because you
can support edge deployments.
You can actually migrate
from Compute Engine,
on-premise, other clouds.
So I think this is going to be
very exciting for the future,
as well.
SONA OAKLEY: Absolutely.
And that's actually
why we're seeing
a lot of financial institutions
have interest in Anthos--
is because they're running these
data-driven applications, which
really hits that sweet spot for
containerization because, you
know, instead of having
a monolithic application,
you can really
break it down into
its appropriate components.
And anything that you need to
put a web or mobile front-end
on top of really lends itself
to that use case very well.
STEPHANIE WONG: So for
those that are wondering,
how can I get started in that
decision-making process, what
is there to recommend?
SONA OAKLEY: Oh my gosh,
there's a number of resources.
I would say that my
favorite is probably--
we have a set of
reference guides
available on
cloud.google.com, which
I think will be linked below,
that are a great Getting
Started guide and help you to
think through what it actually
means to migrate your business.
Also, we have a variety
of professional services,
resources, and-- internally,
that organization
is called PSO.
And so, we can absolutely
leverage workshops
that they have to
help you out, as well.
STEPHANIE WONG: Awesome.
Well, thank you so much
for being on the show.
We went over a ton
of information.
So thanks again.
SONA OAKLEY: Absolutely.
This was a lot of fun.
So thank you so
much for having me.
STEPHANIE WONG: Everyone, I
encourage you all to check out
the resources below.
And check out our other
series, "Stack Chat," where
we go into actual examples
and bring on customers
to talk about how they're
implementing our technology
and migration patterns.
Let us know what you
think of migration.
Are you doing Lift
and Shift, Multicloud?
What tools are you using?
Comment below, and join us next
time for Eyes on Enterprise.
[MUSIC PLAYING]